GBBO S08E05
Noel, what are you doing?!
It's Week 5, we've got eight
bakers waiting.
I'm just frolicking in the fields.
No, you're not.  What?
That's way too fast.
Really? How do you know?
I was European Frolic Champion 1983,
you want to do it like THIS.
That is a frolic.
Wow. Yeah, that's better, actually.
Yeah, ain't that nice?  Anyway, never
mind the frolics -
BOTH: Welcome to The Great British
Bake Off.
Oh, yeah.
Last time...
The bakers went gooey
over caramel.
Oh, my God.
Liam hit the sweet spot...
I love that flavour.
Oh!  ..but Kate...
You can do this, you can do this.
..spun her way to Star Baker.
That's delicious.
It's so original.
James almost came unstuck.  Massive,
aren't they?
They're sizeable.
But having fudged his cake...
Oh, Tom.
..Tom was the fourth baker to say
goodbye.
Going to miss you.
This week...  If it doesn't set, it's
a hot mess.
..puddings.
GASPS
Yeah! Yeah!
A steamy Signature...
Ow, ow, ow - hot.
..a twisted Technical...
Everybody leave, except for Julia.
..and a multi-layered Showstopper...
Come on!  ..that turns bakers...
It's dribbling, it's
dribbling loads.
Look, look!  ..to jelly.
Massive disaster.
It's like watching a horror
film - you don't want to watch it,
you can't peel your eyes away.
I don't like rubber.
Disappointing.
Honestly, I can't believe the high
standard of the bakers this year,
and some of them are so young -
Julia, 21. Liam, 19.
I know, they're just getting younger
and younger,
it's as if Paul's genetically
breeding them in a lab.
Alfie, Frankie, it's all about using
your hand, all right?
You've really got to push in there.
Anyway, dig in.
What's this for?  It's Pudding Week.
Where'd you get that?  I nicked it!
Halfway.
If I can get to Week 7, I'll
be chuffed - Week 8.
I'll be chuffed if I can get to
Week 8.
I've been walking round with a big
grin on my face all week
since getting Star Baker. If
anything, it's made me want to
work harder.
Pudding Week! I had a rubbish week
last week, so lots to improve on.
It was very noticeable last
week, there's not much
separating everybody, now I feel
even more pressure.
I'm totally scared, anybody
could go.
Morning, bakers, welcome to
Pudding Week.
That is a sentence I've uttered
many times,
but now that I'm actually hosting a
baking show, it finally makes sense.
For your Signature Challenge, Prue
and Paul would like you
to go back to a time of assemblies
and uniforms -
a time when Prue was in
short trousers
and Paul had a very nice
Aertex blouse,
because they want you to make
a steamed school pudding.
Your school pudding must be served
with an accompaniment,
like a compote or a custard.
You've got three hours to
get steamy with your school
puddings.
BOTH: On your marks, get set, bake!
I love puddings, puddings with
custard, ice cream.
Now, see if I can make a
good pudding.
What can go wrong? Oh, God.
I love steamed pudding.
I mean, it takes me back to when I
was in school.
It's all about that little bit of
sweetness,
and then the gorgeous texture of a
light sponge.
With custard, ahh - it's one of my
favourite things ever.
Most bakers are very good at things
in the oven,
this time we're asking them to cook
something on top of the cooker.
It's extremely difficult to tell
whether the steam pudding is cooking
correctly.
Anything that's got a
little bit of sogginess to it,
it's a little bit stodgy, is a big
no for me.
Morning.  Morning.  Sophie, tell us
about your steamed school pudding?
I am doing a fig, ginger and honey
steamed pudding
and I'm going to serve it with a
tonka mascarpone cream.
Sorry, a what?  A tonka bean.
That's a first for Bake Off.
Does it smell?  Yeah - please.
Where do you even get those?
Supermarket.
We shop in very different shops.
SHE LAUGHS
Sophie's also adding an exotic twist
to her sponge,
soaking it with honey from Yemen,
served with her cream that should
give a flavour of Latin America.
A spicy vanilla.
People either love it or hate it,
so...
Well, that's a very safe thing
to do.
Whilst puddings can be a little bit
stodgy, you don't want them too
stodgy.
The key thing to get right today is
going to be the sponge.
I've just whisked some egg whites
and they're going into the batter,
adds some more air. It is hard to
make a steamed pudding airy.
We're avoiding stodge at all costs.
If I see any stodge trying to creep
into the tent...
Get out.
The thing is about a stodge,
when you tell a stodge to leave
a tent,
it will do it slowly.
HE LAUGHS
Scientist Yan, however, has a
stodge-avoiding strategy
up her sleeve.
Instead of a third of my flour, I've
put in a third breadcrumbs,
it lightens up the pudding.
To complement her light texture,
she hopes to create an explosion of
fresh flavours
by combining two
varieties of the same fruit.
This is normal mango, this is
Alfonso, the best mango.
Oh, my God, it's so good.
I'm hoping it's going to work.
Unlike Yan and Sophie,
the flavours in Kate's pudding
couldn't get any more
quintessentially English.
I've ground up some Earl Grey tea
and that will go into the sponge.
I'm making
Mr Darcy's Steamy Lake Scene.
Ooh!  Mr Darcy was never at my
school, sadly.
Kate's adding a frisson of lemon to
the delicate bergamot flavour
in her Jane-Austin-inspired pudding.
The Earl Grey won't be lost in it?
No, I'm hoping not.
I think that lemon will be the
overriding flavour.
Hopefully, I'll get the balance
right.
Good luck.
For two of the bakers,
their love of classic English
flavours
has led them down precisely the same
pudding lane.
I love cherry bakewell.
When I was younger, me and my mum
and my sister,
we always used to go to the corner
shop,
so then we'd always get the tinned
version of steamed puddings
and our favourite was, like,
the cherry bakewell version.
I love a bakewell tart.
My husband loves, but we all love
a bakewell tart.
Stacey's doing a bakewell.
I try not to pay that much
attention.
See what happens, isn't it?
To recreate the bakewell pudding of
his youth,
19-year-old Liam's folding glace and
dried cherries
into an almond and
lemon-infused sponge.
I want them to think that the
combination of flavours are good,
that the bake is good.
Yeah, I want to nail both.
The most important thing is that my
pudding is light and fluffy.
It's got to be the bomb. It's got to
be perfect.
Stacey's cherries will flavour the
jam on top of her almond sponge,
and in her bid to win the battle of
the bakewells,
she's left nothing to chance.
Have you practised it?  I've done it
17 times.
17 times?  I'd say about 17 times.
Yeah. I wanted to get it absolutely
perfect.
Well, good luck.  Thank you. Thank
you very much.
Let's see what happens on your 18th
attempt!  Thank you.
I'm just lining the bowl with orange
slices.
These will cook with the sponge,
so they become really soft
and you can actually eat the orange
and the sponge all together.
So it makes it a bit like a
marmalade-y sort of flavour.
James will also soak his sponge in a
ginger syrup
to try and bring to life
the steamed pudding of his boyhood
dreams.
In junior school we always had a
choice of either syrup pudding
or a marmalade pudding, so this is a
combination of both.
So, reminiscent of the school days.
I never had steamed pudding at
school.
It was like, I don't know, some
baked apple
with cottage cheese inside.
It wasn't great.
Having missed out on a lifetime of
steamed puddings,
Russian-born Julia was forced to
call
on her English in-laws for tips.
Treacle pudding, it's my husband
Matt's grandparents' favourite.
So I thought, "I'll make that."
I'm zesting lemons.
The favours I've chosen are quite
classic, quite simple,
but I didn't want to try to be too
clever.
A lemon sponge with blackcurrant
sauce might seem straight-forward,
but being Steven, it's here the
simplicity ends.
Why have you got a syringe?
So we're going to take some of the
liquid from the compote,
inject little streaks into it.
So you'll get a marbled effect?
Almost marbling.  All right, mate.
Good luck, anyway.  Thank you very
much.
I look forward to it.  Thank you.
Right bakers, one hour gone, two
hours left.
I'm just lining the inside of my
pudding basin with slices of fig,
so when you turn it out, they'll be
on the outside.
The thing about steamed pudding,
you just need to get the right
amount of mixture in the bowl -
not too much, not too little.
I'm putting it in.
That takes just under two hours.
It's nicely bubbling away,
and then I'll put it down to low, so
two hours.
Exactly an hour and a half.
Originally, I was doing two hours,
then I went down to an hour and
three quarters,
39.
Now, it's an hour and a half.
It's just literally put it in and
leave it.
Absolutely not touching it, it's a
fatal mistake.
Fatal.
Ooh!
Oh, no.
As their puddings gather steam,
there's still sauces to start...
This is the blackcurrant compote...
..and custards to concoct.
So in the pan, I've got milk, cream
and some cinnamon stick crushed up.
That's going to go into a couple of
eggs
and also some nice chocolate,
as well,
so it'll be a nice thick
chocolaty custard.
My dream custard is thick.
You know when you pour it onto the
cake, you can't see the cake?
It's just like...
I just want to take it a little bit
past runny
because I don't want a thick gloppy
custard,
I want like a nice, light
creme anglaise.
This is Earl Grey.  It's like the
19th century was in the room.
Yes.  Hello, Liam.
The thing is about this,
it's kind of a school pudding from
the '70s
and I imagine they were probably
extinct
by the time you went to school.
Steam puddings did not exist at my
primary school.
So this is quite an odd challenge
for you
because it's sort of
recreating something historical?
Yeah. It's not really, it's a bit
odd.
Unlike Liam, the steamed school
pudding and I go way back.
In fact, our formative years were
spent at the same institution -
Cambridge University.
Up until the 17th century,
the steamed pudding was a far from
sweet affair.
Comprised of an animal's stomach or
even a bladder,
jammed packed with meat and veg.
For the cooks at Cambridge,
mass pudding-making would have an
onerous task.
You put the contents in and then you
tied it up and then you boiled it.
And, trust me, it really smells.
Yeah.  Not only that, it's liable to
break.
Obviously, people from Cambridge
came and went
and someone has decided,
instead of using a sheep's bladder,
why not use a cloth?
So you've got people replacing the
meat with suet, putting flour in,
but then also adding sugar.
Sugar would have been too expensive
for most folks in 1615,
but not for the scholars of
Cambridge.
Adding this, along with the flour
and suet, created a lighter,
cake-like texture, resulting in the
Cambridge pudding.
Why can we date is so specifically?
Because it comes in a book
printed in 1615.
Mince suet, new milk, warm, fine
sugar and eggs.
There's theory and then there's the
practicality -
we need to make a pudding.
Luckily, I have all the ingredients
for a Cambridge pudding
and culinary historian,
Dr Sue Bailey,
tucked away in my old dorm room.
This looks absolutely fantastic.
Now, I'm desperate for your help,
Sue.
Thank you, Sandi.  I've got the
recipe, it's frankly unclear.
Mince suet, is that grated suet?
It is grated suet.
This is what has been actually
rendered down.
I'm going to put all of this in.
Fatty pudding. Taken from round the
loins
and the kidneys of beef and
mutton, suet's a calorific fat,
perfect for satisfying hungry
students,
whilst negating the need for meat.
You now have to do a little sort of
dent in the middle,
because otherwise, you're not going
to be able to fit the butter in.
I've actually never seen this much
butter going into one thing.
Then we put them on top of each
other.
On top of each other, so.
Wow, look at that.
I can actually feel my
cardiovascular system
having a little seizure.
Mm. It's nice, isn't it?
Thanks to the clever cooks of
Cambridge,
the sweet steamed pudding was born,
and sheep's bladders faded from
school menus,
much to the relief of pupils
and dinner ladies across the nation.
Bakers, you have 30 minutes left,
30 minutes.
It's time to take it out of there
now, I'm terrified.
If you open it and it's sunk in the
middle,
there is no going back from that.
You cannot hide it.  There's just no
way of knowing.
I'm a bit worried.  Three minutes.
Am I the only one who's taking it
out?
I feel so sick.
Someone else open it for me.
Is this quite a moment?
Is that hot?  Ow, ow, ow, ow!
I'm too scared to even do it.
I just want it to be good.
Oh!
Yeah, yeah!
Good, I'm pleased with it.
Why don't you open it, and I'll look
and tell you how good or bad it is.
Please, don't be mean.  OK.
Put the lid back on.
I'm joking, that's all right, isn't
it?
Please, please, please.
A bit of sinkage in the middle.
Oh. Yes, so far so good.
I just need to...
You don't know until you turn it out
whether it's right or not.
Yes.
That is beautiful, it looks steamed,
it looks pudding-like.
Ah, thank gosh for that.
I'm happy with the way it looks.
Right, just serving it like that.
Ta-da. It looks all right, the
mangoes are done.
It's a bit more rustic than the kind
of thing I like to bake.
Ah, it's all right - nothing to see
here.
Oh.  That happens every time I do it.
It's perfect.
How long have we got?  Bakers, you've
got five minutes left.
It's not thickening, I don't
understand.
How long has it been on?  Ages.
How can I help?  You can't.
Wow, that's the sort of thing you
used to make cows with.
I want that juice to be all the way
through the sponge.
I'm basically giving these mangoes
a shave.
I'm making a raspberry flour.
Look at that, that is the nuts, that
is.
I'm sorry, that is very good,
actually.
Oh, stand up!
It's not thickening, so what I'm
doing
is just putting a little bit more of
the cornflour in.
Right, bakers, you have one minute
before we ring the school bell.
What a disaster.
Bakers, time is up, pencils down,
the exam is over.
Please place your steamed school
puddings at the end of your desks.
Absolute disaster.
Eight school puddings steamed
and served...
..ready for examination by
Paul and Prue.
I must say, it looks very pretty.
My mouth's watering.
It's not the lightest sponge
I've ever had.
On the other hand, you've got the
orange there.
It is nice and marmaladey.
Paddington Bear'll be pleased.
It's my pet name for Paul!
HE LAUGHS
It is a little bit dense.
I wouldn't say it's a great
steamed pudding,
but it's a very good
steamed pudding.
I'll take that.
Well done.
Thank you.
Nice custard, looks good.
The taste of the orange and the
treacle together, it works.
Not the lightest sponge,
but it is delicious.
It looks a little stodgy.
This is going to be interesting with
the mascarpone cream.
That tonka taste is very
extraordinary and rather good.
The flavour of the
pudding's delicious.
The ginger and the fig really work
together, and the honey.
I'm still unsure about the
tonka bean.
I love it, just too stodgy.
Yep.
I love the effect of the fruits that
have fallen down
and the darkness hitting the lemon
sponge, I think that really works.
Looks very good.
That sponge looks so light.
Blackcurrant is a nice little burst
of acidity.
It should be sharp against the, sort
of, mellow lemon of the sponge.
And it's really good.
It is a beautiful sponge, it tastes
amazing, it is light.
APPLAUSE
Well done, mate, well done.
Thank you.  Fantastic.
The custard's embarrassing.
SHE LAUGHS
That's not custard,
that's a big mistake.
It's quite powerful, but I don't get
the Earl Grey.
You've got Earl Grey fighting
against lemon,
it's going to lose every day
of the week.
It really looks good, it's dramatic,
it's beautifully designed.
Held together well.
Nice consistency.  Yeah.
Mmm.
That is good mango.
It's beautiful and light.
It's lovely.
It's absolutely delicious.
Thank you.  Well done.  Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
Two handshakes.
Thank you, Yan.  Thank you.
I think it's very pretty.
I love the cherries on the top.
Oh, that looks lovely and light.
Very almondy,
proper Bakewell flavour.
HE LAUGHS
It's too stodgy.
OK.  You've probably mixed it
too much
and the gluten's got quite powerful
and that's why I couldn't give you
a handshake.
Ah!
Do you want a Fielding fondle?
LAUGHTER
Don't leave me hanging!
It looks quite attractive.
The sponge looks pretty good.
Oh, that looks really good,
nice and light.
Absolutely delicious.
One of my favourite things is
Bakewell tarts.
You have the texture of a Bakewell
tart in there, which is very clever.
Cherry's got that sharpness
to it as well.
So overall,
it's a very special thing.
SHE LAUGHS
It's absolutely delicious.
Oh!
Thank you.
APPLAUSE
So close.
I'm really happy,
and I got a handshake.
He really did not want to give me
one because he'd given two already,
do you know what I mean,
which makes it even more brilliant
that I got one.
I'm well chuffed.
SHE GIGGLES
I always make custard,
what was that?!
That was embarrassing.
It was like a milk drink.
I don't think I'm looking forward to
the Technical that much.
Does anyone look forward to a
Technical Challenge?
I don't think they do.
Not only are the bakers about to
face the total unknown,
this week, it's a Technical
with a twist.
Hello, bakers.
Today, your Technical
Pudding Challenge has been set by
Mr Paul Hollywood.
So Paul, any advice
before you leave the tent?
It's all about the timing.
Well, that's totally clear, I feel.
Now, as you know for this bit, Paul
and Prue are not allowed to stay.
We'll see them later. Off you go.
Right.  Today's Technical Challenge
is staggering.
Yes, we are going to be staggering
your start times.
We're going to call you in one by
one and tell you what the challenge
is at your start time.
So everybody leave except for...
Julia.
Out you come, come on.
Off you go.
Come on, no messing about.
Are you all right, Julia?
No.
For today's Technical Challenge,
Paul would like you to make six
molten chocolate puddings filled
with peanut butter.
You have one hour, and at exactly
that point, you have to present your
bake for judging.
On your marks.
Get set.
Bake!  Bake.
Melt the chocolate and butter
together, whisk the eggs,
egg yolks and sugar together,
combine the two mixtures.
I've done it once,
but it was such a long time and it
was just filled with chocolate.
OK, melt the chocolate
back together.
Let me show you something, Prue.
So what we've got is a chocolate
molten cake with a beautiful peanut
butter filling,
which oozes out when
you cut it.
These are designed to be eaten hot,
straight from the oven.
So we're staggering their starts and
we'll judge them live.
You bake these for ten minutes.
Over bake, then the whole
mixture will congeal,
and you won't get that goo
when you cut it.
It's got to run.
If they under do it, the whole thing
will just collapse.
Do you know what, I think this is a
really tricky challenge.
And I will be astonished if
everybody produces perfection.
It is so weird being on my own.
I'm petrified,
I'm absolutely petrified.
It's all about timing. We have to
serve it on the hour.
Right, baker number two, for your
Technical Challenge,
Paul would like you to make six
molten chocolate puddings filled
with hot peanut butter.
You have one hour.
On your marks.
Get set.  Bake.
Never made one.
So I suppose, actually, I've got to,
you know, really think about when
they go in the oven
because they have to be, you know,
still runny in the middle.
Potentially, they could sort
of carry on cooking, so...
Oh, it's a mine field.
I'm just melting my chocolate with
some butter.
Well, at least I'm not on my own
right now, which makes it
a bit better.
Hi.
Does it? Does it actually
make it better?  No.
No. No, it doesn't.
Just got to melt some chocolate,
just melt some chocolate.
Baker number three, for your
Technical Challenge,
Paul would like you to make six
molten chocolate puddings.
You've got one hour.
Bake!  Bake.
I've never made them before, but I
know what they look like.
Thum, thum, thum, thum, thum, thum.
What do I need?
I've got the butter and
chocolate melting,
and then I'm just about to start
whisking up the eggs and sugar.
There's no raising agent in this
at all.
The raising comes from
the whisked eggs.
Yeah, you need loads of air in it.
MOTOR WHIRRING
I can't believe I'm doing it
by hand.
Baker number four, on your marks.
Get set.  Bake!
I have absolutely no idea.
I'm going with ribbon stage,
which means there should be a bit of
a trail left behind.
Everything you do,
you second guess yourself.
Should I be doing it that way?
What's that word I like,
trepidatious?
Baker number five.
You have one hour.
On your marks.  Get set.
Bake!
Oh, yeah, that's OK.
I've made this before, similar.
Not peanut butter, though.
It's OK, I've got it.
What am I doing?
So I've just whisked the eggs.
I'm trying to let the chocolate cool
a little bit more.
I just don't like the idea of adding
hot chocolate to like a cold egg
sugar mix.
Oh, have I turned my oven on?
Yes. Oh!
I need to combine the two together.
It doesn't say anything, how to
combine or what to do.
How's it going?
Yeah, it should be all right, I just
need to crack on really.
I don't really know what I'm doing.
Are you saying I'm in your way, what
are you saying, Liam?
I think I'm doing it right, but I'm
not entirely sure.
Baker number six,
for your Technical Challenge,
Paul would like you to make six
molten chocolate puddings.
You have one hour.
Bake!
I've never made a chocolate pudding
in my life.
So, brilliant.
So I've just added two tablespoons
of flour.
I don't want to knock out
the air bubbles,
so that's why I'm folding it gently.
Baker number seven, on your marks.
Get set.  Bake!
Never made them before in my life.
Fortunately, in revision last night,
I briefly glanced through molten
volcano cakes, which is similar.
I'm a little more confident than
I'm letting on.
HE LAUGHS
It says "divide it between moulds".
I'm sort of starting out putting the
sort of same amount in each because
they will want them identical.
I've weighed them out,
dead on 100g in each pot.
I've filled three quarters of the
way up, and they're going to rise.
I don't want them billowing
over the top.
Baker number eight, on your marks.
Get set.  Bake!
Not a clue.
I'm just putting my peanut butter
inside of them.
Well, it says "teaspoon", but with a
bit of an extra.
A heaped teaspoon.
I'm having a terrible dilemma
at the moment.
My main problem is, I'm not sure
whether I'm supposed to whisk that
up to a frenzy
or not whisk it up a lot,
but my heart is telling me to really
go for it.
But, then again, my brain is telling
me maybe don't go for it.
I think it's a light folding.
Fingers crossed that this is the
right way to do it.
The plan is to let them freeze off
for 15 minutes.
When you cook it, it makes it molten
in the middle.
I've got probably about ten minutes
in the freezer,
just to chill them down and then
it's item six, bake.
Baking time, that's what it's all
down to, and I have no idea.
How long?  How long to do it for.
Well, I've got an inkling.
An inkling.
I've got an inkling, and I think
it's not very long.
The undisclosed bake time for Paul's
recipe is ten minutes.
I've got 20 minutes left.
I'm going to bake them for, I'm not
sure, 12 minutes.
You don't want them over baked,
so I'll probably give them like...
Like 20, 15 minutes.
Oh, I don't know.
No idea, no idea.
Eight minutes.
I'm going to say it's probably about
35 minutes.
Obviously, I don't want them
to be raw.
Oh, you're kidding me!
The oven wasn't on.
Come on.
Eight more minutes.
15 left, eight more minutes.
25 minutes.
They're going in now, they can heat
up with the oven.
The key thing with baking is that
you want the outside crispy,
so that it holds the gooey centre.
180 for 10 minutes.
If you go too far, you just get a
rock hard sponge.
Too little,
it's just going to splodge.
So you just need the right balance,
which is going to be tricky.
They really should be in now.
I didn't want to be early,
but now I think I'm late.
It's a waiting game now.
Come on, you can do this.
Baker number one, you've got
one minute left.
I don't think they're done.
As ever in a Technical Challenge,
Paul and Prue will blind taste
the bakes.
Baker number one, your time is up,
and I'm going to come and collect
your molten chocolate puddings.
Baker number one.
Ah, thank you.
These actually look very neat,
don't they?
They do, don't they.
Let's have a look.
That's good.
Look at the texture of the peanut,
it's soft still, pouring out.
Yeah, that's good.
I have no idea what they're saying,
I can't hear anything.
Let's just have a quick taste.
Could have done with a
touch more filling,
but, I must say, it's not bad.
Baker number two, your time is up.
Thank you very much, waiter.
Very neat again. A bit of a wobble,
which is good.
We need to really get into it.
Oh, look at that!
Look at that.
Now you're talking.
That's more peanut butter, that's
what makes the difference.
And it's good.
They look good, the flavour of the
chocolate's good.
That's excellent.
I saw a lot of nodding.
Baker number three,
I am coming to collect your
molten chocolate puddings.
I know they're under, so under.
I mean, you've got a
little bit of goo.
Let's have a taste of it and see.
It's very good.
The sponge is excellent.
The texture's pretty good as well.
I just think if they'd put more
peanut butter in it, it would have
been better.
Absolutely.
They're coming out.
Time is up.
That's wonderful news.  I'll be
gentle with them.
They look...  They look perfect,
don't they?
I think these are going to be
excellent.
Oh, it's quite solid.
Not quite runny enough.
Slightly over, aren't they?
What a pity, I thought we had a
winner here.
Baker number five, your time is up.
Wow, got to be careful how you serve
that one.
Baker number five.
Wow, thank you very much.
PAUL LAUGHS
If you're going to serve a cake,
serve it phallic.
Whoa!  It's not cooked.
It is under baked.
If you like undercooked cake
mixture...  Chocolate sponge, yeah.
..you'd like it.
Oh, I've overcooked these.
Oh, they look horrible.
Baker number six, your time is up.
If you drop them,
it wouldn't be a disaster!
LAUGHTER
Wish them luck.
Enjoy.  I don't think we will!
Oh, dear. It's cracked.
They're quite solid.
Oh, yeah, they are.
Let's have a look.
Yeah, see, massively overbaked.
It's like watching, like,
a horror film.
You don't want to watch it, you
can't peel your eyes away.
It looks pretty dreadful, really.
Right, baker number seven,
your time is up.
One collapsed because I threw it
down too hard,
but at least I know it's
soft in the middle.
OK, this has got a few issues with
getting it out of the mould.
This one's broken, this is dipping,
that's got a big air hole in.
Let's cut this one.
Yeah, that's absolutely raw, look.
So's this one. That's raw as well.
It's a bit of a failure.
Yeah, they're a bit burnt.
Baker number eight, your time is up.
God, almighty.
Voila!  Thank you.
Thank you very much.
There's not a lot of middle,
is there?
It looks slightly overbaked to me.
This is horrible.
I just don't want to be last.
They taste OK, the chocolate's good.
I'm a little bit worried about
folding of the mix
because there are little air pockets
and cracks.
Sophie, what are they saying?
There's just not enough middle.
No.  Not enough peanut butter.
It's good,
but it's just not perfect.
Pru and Paul will now rank
the molten puddings
from the worst to the best.
In eighth place, who's that?
That's me.  Kate, that's you.
Well, they've collapsed,
haven't they?
In seventh place is this one.
James, it wasn't baked enough
cos all the chocolate was still
coming out with the peanut butter.
OK.
In sixth place, it's Yan.
Fifth, is Steven
and Stacey is fourth.
In third spot is this one.
Pretty good, actually, Julia.
I just think
that you could have done with
a little bit more peanut butter in
there and it would have flooded out.
And in second place...
This one. Who's that?
Liam, well done.
They really are excellent.
In first place is this one.
APPLAUSE
Well done.  Awesome.
Thank you.
'I'm pleased, actually.
I needed this'
and it's put me in a much better
position going forward to tomorrow.
That was sick. Yeah.
Ooh!
A little bit gutted,
a new day tomorrow.
I'm not beating myself up about it.
It's not the end of the world,
it's a pudding.
It's the Showstopper.
One last chance to prove
they are worthy of Star Baker,
or simply that they deserve to stay.
Right, my gorgeous judges.
Three handshakes.
It's a personal best for you.
When Stacy, Stephen, Yan
create something that is pure magic
and perfection...
You've got to give it a handshake.
I've got to give them a handshake.
Who for you is in trouble this week?
PRUE:  James is in trouble.
I adore James, I really don't want
him to mess up, but he just could.
I think Kate as well.
Kate was Star Baker last week,
but I think she is in trouble.
She was bottom of technical.
So, coming in to the Showstopper,
she really has the pull out
all the stops.
What if you're in the middle,
you could go up or down.
Oh, yeah ,absolutely.  You have
totally understood mathematics,
and I like that about you.
I know. I didn't even go to school.
Heart's beating...
Morning, bakers. I hope you had
sweet pudding dreams.
Now, for your Showstopper today,
Prue and Paul would like you to make
an ornamental trifle terrine.
You'll need three things.
A baked element,
a set custard or a mousse,
and a jelly.
Without those three things,
it's just chaos.
And everyone must want a slice.
The slice needs to look as good
as the whole.
You've got four and half hours.
On your marks...  Get set.  Bake!
Four and a half hours seems
like a lifetime,
but I know this is going
to rapidly go.
The Showstopper Challenge today,
it's all about textures,
definitive layers,
and beautiful flavours.
The jelly is going to be
the most difficult one,
because it has to be firm enough to
be sliced, but not to be rubbery.
This is a masterclass in gelatine.
Because if you don't set the jelly,
the whole thing will collapse
when you bring it out.
Starting off with the
raspberry jelly,
because that's the first layer,
so that needs to get into the
freezer as quickly as possible.
I'm just squeezing out my
oranges for my jelly.
In the topsy-turvy world
of terrines,
the bottom layer becomes the top.
I'm making pineapple,
rum and mint jelly.
So, getting it set early
is a priority.
I'm just soaking some leaf gelatine.
I'm using powdered gelatine,
it gives it, like, a really
luminous orange,
if it sets.
This is the lemon-and-lime jelly.
It's going to be blue, so we're
going to add a blue liqueur.
Because I've decided to do a
hidden design,
I have to use a lot of gelatine,
which can make things a bit rubbery.
We'll find out.
Stephen's American flag trifle will
have raspberry jelly with white
chocolate coconut custard stripes
and his stars should magically
appear when sliced.
How are you going to do that?
Layering blue jelly
and then pipe rows of stars
with a white chocolate,
butter and sugar mix.
When you cut it, you should get
the stars and stripes.
Wow.  How many stars are you actually
going to put on it?
I have been to nine states in
America, so I'm doing nine.
I'm really looking forward to
seeing how this turns out.
Me too.
Stephen's not the only baker flying
the flag for trifle.
I'm just laying out the fruit
in the Union Jack pattern.
I call it the
Missed Silver Jubilee terrine.
When I was about six, I missed the
street party that we had
outside our house because
I had chickenpox.
Mum brought me up a trifle and that
is what I remember
about the Silver Jubilee.
A rubbish day, basically.
James's regret-tinged trifle will
layer Swiss roll, Eton mess mousse,
and raspberry panna cotta.
Topped with a fruity Union Jack
in proseco jelly.
When you cut a slice,
you'll just see stripes?
Yes, so it should be
red, white, blue.
Then you won't see the
Union Jack any more.
Yes.
Well, good luck.
It's not just James whose patriotic
spirit has been stirred up by the
Great British trifle.
My terrine is called
Heart of a Hero.
Dad was in the Royal Navy,
stationed in Hong Kong.
He was then allowed to bring his
family over to the UK.
It's about him risking everything,
mum and dad risking everything
to come over.
Encircled by chocolate cityscapes,
Yan's trifle will sandwich
sponge with strawberry and white
chocolate mousses,
crowned with an ambitious
jelly poppy.
I've set jelly aside, just clear.
I'll use the syringe to inject
the red jelly, let it set,
and then the black colour, yeah.
Very clever.  Well, let's
see if it works.
Good luck.  Thank you.
All right, this can go in the fridge
to start chilling.
Let's get this baby in the freezer.
The last layer of blue is
just chilling out.
Then we're going to start with the
red, white, red.
That's my raspberry mousse.
This is my Eton mess layer.
So, I'm making the
strawberry mousse.
Whipped up the cream melt in a
packet of strawberry jelly,
and then pureed 200g
of strawberries
and then push it through a sieve,
because it is the Bake Off.
Just adding my yuzu to my custard.
The idea of this was just born
from a flavour.
It's a citrus fruit.
They use it a lot in Japan.
I'm fascinated by Japanese pastry,
I love it.
Sophie's yuzu flavour will run
through her sponge and custard
with a hidden core of yuzu curd
and raspberry mousse.
How are you going to get that in
there?  So, that's actually
already in the freezer, so I've got
a mini version of this.
This mould, what's it called?
This is a buche mould.
Mighty Boosh mould?  I think it is.
The Mighty Boosh or the mini Boosh?
I'm very excited.
All right, I think we better
ferme our buche and go.
Thank you very much indeed.
Right, let's make a sponge.
I'm making my raspberry and
almond sponge.
I'm not mucking about with
the pink today.
I'm going for it.
This is a savoyarde sponge,
which is the stuff of
ladyfinger biscuits.
This is going right at the bottom.
It needs to be a decent thickness.
I think the key import to this
is keeping the strata.
So, you don't want it to sink
into the below layer.
It's not as thick as I'd
like it to be,
but let's just see.
Just love this colour.
Stacy's flamboyant sponge will join
layers of rum and pineapple jelly,
passion fruit, Eton mess and
mango mousse laced with chilli,
all perched on a coconut
biscuit base.
OK, I'm trying to get my head right.
So, there are five layers?
Yes, but there is also,
going around the outside,
fuchsia pink passion fruit
meringues.
Wow...  I think this sounds
like Stacy.
It's ambitious, there's about
20 different things to do.
So, I'm putting them on 170 degrees
for, like, half an hour?
Get it baked.  Ten to 12 minutes.
But sponge...
Right.
..isn't everyone's cup of tea.
I've got brown butter brownies.
It's inspired by my friends at uni.
Whenever we have a break
or whatever,
we always have brownies and, like,
chai latte.  Chai latte?
"Yeah, yeah, it was really popular
in university last year."
What?
Liam's ode to student life will
layer orange jelly, chai latte,
panna cotta and chocolate mousse
on top of his brownie base.
I love the idea of the flavours.
Chai latte?  They go to a very,
like, artsy, like, university.
Well, I did actually go to
art school myself. So did you.
So did I.  So, you are speaking to
two art students here.
We invented the chai latte.
Not everyone's trifles are
quite so trendy.
Going for traditional trifle.
I've got my great, great nan to
thank for this recipe.
As with any good old-fashioned
trifle,
raspberry will flavour Kate's
meringue cream sponge and jelly,
with a layer of thick-set
powdered custard.
Well, these are classic flavours.
Sometimes, you can't move too far
away from tradition.
Keeping it simple.
One hour gone.
Sponge coming out of the oven.
Should be perfect.
Beautiful.
It's the most amazing pink,
isn't it?
Is the jelly set?
My orange jelly is not setting as
fast as it normally does.
At home, it takes, like,
half an hour to freeze over,
but I don't know what's
going on here.
It's set.  It's taking ages.
And like magic...
I'm just soaking sponge in
a fruit juice.
So, when I turn it out,
I've got a lovely, colourful trifle.
Julia's vanilla and liqueur-soaked
summer fruit sponges will surround
passion fruit jelly,
topped with chocolate mousse.
Are trifles popular in Siberia?
I've never in my life seen trifle.
What's trifle, then, in Russian?
I don't know.
Bakers, you have had half the time
for your ornamental trifle terrines.
The jelly just hasn't set.
Right, raspberry jelly.
There is a lot to do. Now I'm moving
on to the chai latte panna cotta.
Let's see what happens.
Let me not panic.
I'm just getting started on
the Eton mess.
When I practised it, the Eton mess
has been a mess.
I'm not a big fan of trifles.
Back to the sad day of when I
couldn't go to the Silver Jubilee.
What's next?  I'm doing my
custard next.
Just adding my yuzu custard.
Coconut custard.
Quite unconventional.
This whisks our custard powder.
Can't have a trifle without
a custard powder.
Shocking ingredients.
Do you like making these terrines?
No, not really.
You know, any future husband better
not be getting ideas off this.
If I ever get married, which is
highly unlikely at this stage...
Why?  I don't know.
Like, is this a conversation?
Seriously, you cook and you're
a blacksmith.
That's, like, the perfect
combination.  Am I going red?
You are, darling. I don't think this
is the best way for you to pull.
Bakers, one and a half hours left
on your trifle terrines.
I'm actually ahead of time.
We are, we're halfway up the flag.
I'm making a thin coconut biscuit
to finish off.
This is the white
chocolate bavarois,
which is going to envelop
the insert.
Chocolate mousse, the layer that can
make or break my terrine.
HE LAUGHS
This is going to be a
mango-lime chilli mousse,
just mango, lime,
and chilli in there,
and then I'm going to be
putting cream in.
I'm just making my Swiss roll.
A red sponge because, obviously,
we want it to match the colour
of the flag.
Just worried it's not pink enough.
Done.  Let's get this in the freezer.
Let it set.
MACHINE BEEPS
All done.
Now it's a waiting game.
Bakers, you've got half an hour
to put that welly in your jelly.
The terrine is in the freezer,
so decorations, in the meantime,
really.
You've certainly hit the '80s.
That's the plan.
Chocolate skyline of Hong Kong.
And London.  Build the future.
In chocolate?  In chocolate.
Totally.
I'm just making my topping.
HE GASPS
Massive disaster.
I've forgotten the sugar
in my biscuit.
No sugar. Got to do it again.
It's funny, isn't it? As soon as you
get in the tent, you just ruin it.
I've got to pipe the poppy.
So, this is gelatine and
I'm just colouring it.
Spot the scientist.
I'm just putting some silver leaf on
to the little meringue crowns.
I can do it better than that.
I want to make another one.
Come on, you can do this.
All I have to do is take the terrine
out of it's mould,
with a cool biscuit underneath.
But the biscuit isn't cool because
it is in the oven now.
Bit of a problem.
Amazing.  It is called
Heart of a Hero.
That's my dad's heart.
He's a hero.
That is so clever, dude.
I'm just waiting for my
terrine to set.
Fingers crossed
it will come out firm.
Or a nice wash.
Can you imagine?
Happy with it?  Can't really tell
until it is unmolded.
Ah, it's nerve-racking.
Really soft, so I'm just going to
do it really gently.
Come on.  I feel sick.
Come on, you can do this.
Oh, wow. That's beautiful.
Is the jelly set?
Not great. Hasn't quite
frozen solid.
15 minutes left.
15 minutes only.
Make or break.  That's my girl.
Trying to get it as smooth
as possible.
It's dribbling, it's dribbling.
It's dribbling in loads, it's...
Look, look! It's an absolute mess.
Stop panicking.  It's dribbling.
And it's a mess.
Really need them to speed up,
I am stressing out.
It's not going to set.
Someone tell me it's going
to be fine.
It's dripping, it's dripping.
It's fine. It's all fine.
It's all fine.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Ta-da. Oh.
Bakers, that is the end of your
Showstopper Challenge.
Done.
Are you OK?
Are you all right, babe?
I don't know what happened
to my orange jelly...
HE SIGHS
Sophie, please bring up your
ornamental trifle terrine.
It's wonderful that you got your
pink sausage in the middle.
Yeah.
I like the look of it, I love the
colours.
Wow, it drops through lovely.
Well, that worked, didn't it?
Beautiful.  The slice is pretty, very
good slice.
And that yuzu really comes through.
That's absolutely delicious.
Brilliant.  Really good.
The sponge...
..the bavarois, the mousse, the
jelly...
I think, altogether, you've created
something very pretty, very
high-class.
Really delicious.
Amazing, isn't it?  I actually love
it.
And to get the gelatine to create
the poppy - it's very clever.
Wow.
The strawberry mousse is a triumph!
But, who doesn't like strawberry
mousse?
The custard, I think you've got a
little bit too much gelatine in
there.
It's just set on the wrong side of
firm, but it looks incredible.
Thank you.
Well, it's certainly jolly.
Pink is proper pink, isn't it?
Yeah.
Well, the slice is pretty, isn't it?
This is spot-on.
The lime, the mint...
..the chilli!
Who would have a chilli in a trifle?
But it works, that little heat at
the end is fascinating.
The biscuit down in the bottom is
delicious.
Meringues around the outside,
again, genius.
I think you come up with something
that is truly unique,
and tastes beautiful.
It's neat, it's clean, stark lines.
The difference in colour's
phenomenal.
The jelly is very nice, and tart,
and really raspberry!
It's delicious. The custard takes me
back a few years.
I used a bit of custard powder.
Me Nan used to do something very
similar to that.
It's very good.
It does look a bit firm.
It's too firm on all of it.
White chocolate is very sweet.
The best bit is the prosecco jelly
on the top.
All the other layers are not
carrying much flavour.
It's a bit sickly.
Overall, I think the appearance is
all right, actually.
I'm fascinated to see what it's
like inside.
Right.
I don't think the jelly works,
funnily enough,
although I love passion fruit.
It almost tastes watery.
The passion fruit isn't strong
enough for me.
The texture and everything is OK,
that soggy sponge, though,
I just don't get.
That's a shame.
Oh!  Oh!  Look at that!
Wow.
Isn't that fantastic?
Ha!
It's very clever.
The stars are amazing.
Thank you.
The coconut flavour's lovely.
It's a little tough.
Hmm...
..disappointing.
I don't like rubber...
Yeah.  ..and it is, it's too much
gelatine in there.
I think you've gone for appearance
rather than textures.
Yeah.
It's not good.
OK.
It's a shame, cos it looks amazing.
Everyone's had a style over
substance, at least once.
I think it a bit clumsy, and the
jelly's not set.
Yeah, it's...yeah.  Wow!
It's like water, that jelly,
isn't it?
LIAM SCOFFS
I do get the chai.
Chai latte panna cotta is delicious.
Chocolate brownie...
..is quite tough.
And your jelly is a disaster.
VOICEOVER:  I'd like to stay in, but
I think I'm in the danger zone.
And there's a few of us who are
quite worried, I think, tonight.
VOICEOVER:  Oh, I hope I'm...I will
be here next week, but...
SHE SNIFFS
..I really don't think so.
VOICEOVER:  I just hope they see it
was just a blip.
I just hope they see past it.
HE SIGHS
Right, who's vying for
the top place?
I thought Sophie's was delicious.
If you walked into a
Michelin-starred restaurant
and had that, you wouldn't
argue it.  It's absolutely superb.
What about Stacey?  Very clever.
Every layer was good.
She's definitely a contender.
What about Kate?
Has she saved herself?
I think she has saved herself.
It's not the first time
that Kate's done that.
The whole thing together as one when
you eat it is absolutely delicious,
and actually quite elegant, too.
The one who I wanted
to weep for is Liam.
It's all too clumsy.
I, sort of, weep for him, as well.
He could do better than that,
and he knows that, as well.
The other one who I think
is in trouble is James.
Fantastic jelly.
Problem for me is every other
element was wrong.
Julia's was really disappointing.
She had a passion-fruit jelly
with very little flavour.
Julia, yeah, she's put herself
into a bit of trouble.
Well, you've got a lot to decide.
Meanwhile, we'll just double-check
that this is, you know...
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Right, bakers, I get
the best job of the week,
cos I get to announce
the Star Baker.
The Star Baker this week is
the baker whose terrine,
the four of us have literally
just finished off,
cos it was so delicious.
The Star Baker is...
..Sophie.
APPLAUSE
Which means that I've got
the horrible job of revealing
who's leaving us.
The person that we have
to say goodbye to is...
..James.
I'm sorry, mate.
I'm so sorry.  That's all right.
SHE QUIETLY SOBS
Thanks, Paul.
Unlucky, buddy.
VOICEOVER:  My time has come.
It's gutting.
I wanted to do this to put myself
against other really good bakers
to see how good I was.
To be part of that has been
really humbling.
PRUE:  We will miss James
in the tent.
Julia was sobbing her eyes out,
and who was comforting her?
Don't get me going. I'm not crying.
That's typical of James.
He's just such a nice guy.
Well done, Sophie. That was
delicious.  Thank you very much.
VOICEOVER:  With the Showstopper,
Sophie stepped up to the plate,
and produced one of those
bakes that you just
want to go back for again
and again and again and again.
Yeah, Star Baker.
I will try and enjoy the moment,
before I start thinking
about next week.
But, yeah, I'm really chuffed.
Are you OK?  Yeah.
It was really important
that I did well yesterday,
because if I didn't...
All I need to do next week is just
pick myself back up and just keep
on going upwards.
That's how I'm going to do it.
That's the plan. That's the plan.
Next time...
Whoa.
..pastry. A decorative Signature
with shortcrusts worthy
of "Piecasso".
The little hearts,
absolutely beautifully done.
A technical tart that
causes Portuguese panic.
I think it's turned
to scrambled egg.
And a showstopping pie.
Lot of meat.
..with a crust...
I can't believe I'm so stupid.
..that lands the bakers...
In my opinion, that's
not a hand-raised pie.
..in very hot water.
I'm leaking, but maybe
they won't notice.
That... That could happen.
Subtitles by Ericsson